we can't get enough of the endless  surprises taking place over on the drew  barrymore excuse me drew barrymore show  this week and who would have thought  drew would be this excited to meet a  psychopathic serial killer wait wait  what now by that we mean penn badgley  the star of netflix's psychological  thriller you drew had the biggest  fangirl moment when penn made a virtual  appearance even causing her to fall to  the ground take a look we'll see you  back here next time bye bye-bye so i  decided i need to give you  you and by you i mean penn badgley what  is this is this where i say something  [Applause]  this is  [Applause]  [Laughter]  oh my god  [Applause]  hold on  wow look your best get get together  there we  all go i'm actually sick and i'm in  london  but i'm good we could take care of you  yes i'm available  um this baby comes right off